Một tháng mời một đen lệ dễ nàn à cách tổ chức tại Hàn Quốc.
Tổng thống liên trên mian đã có khuổi đàn với chủ tịch Trung Quốc tập cình bình.
Đây là cuộc gặp đồng tiền giữa hai nhà lĩnh đạo.
Kể từ khi ở linh nhận chức khuổi tháng só nâng này.
Tổng thống hoàn Quốc bây tổ hoàn ngành trường tham của chủ tịch tập cình bình.
Trường tham đồng tiên tế Hàn Quốc sau mùi một năm.
Và khi vào cuộc gặp tương định sẽ mang lại cái quả thích được trình như dần này nữa.
Hà đen thống nhất tăng cường cho đổi trữ lượng.
Thôi đầy hợp tắc kinh tế cùng có lời và hỗ trợ nỗ lực nối này đối thoại với trữ tiền.
Chú tích tập cình bình khẳng đen Trung Quốc có chẳng quan hệ với Hàn Quốc.
Tổng tham sẽ với hợp chạp trẻ để của mừng phó khách tất.
Và tuần đẩy khoản hệ nối tá chỉ lượng phát triển ở đen lông xanh.
Vô hợp với lợi íc vàng miệnh vọng của những dần hành hợp.